no
no eloquent with my words very
diplomatic with my words I'm very
straightforward with my words but
somehow the word toxic came into play
and uh
I find that to be astonishing at this
point explain at this juncture please
elaborate because at the end of the day
what I was saying was straight very
straightforward so why would you think
why would you feel because I know it's
feeling why would you feel like like
toxic that's not that's sexy how could
you think I was moved like
oh never mind okay okay but by the way
I will own it I don't want no goody
goody two shoes no way I would love a
man to what to deal with jungle Justice
a bit more think outside the the lines
of Justice because the Law changes from
country to Country the law is that a lot
of the time
all I'm saying is that actually I would
like to be with somebody that could
rebel against the system because that's
the only thing he's not going to last
long
you see when you talk like that do you
understand yeah that guys a lot of time
are are heavily influenced by what girl
or what is perceived that girls want So
when you say stuff I want a guy that's
gonna work by jungle justice but I'm
just saying Tarzan what are you talking
about bro you live in a in a first world
country yeah where there's laws and
regulations and if you don't abide by
the law you probably will end up I mean
they want no black British man then no
but it doesn't matter if he's there's
loads of yardies in jail there's loads
of Freshies in jail so we talking about
that I think this one right now
and another aspect of the of this is
also when you are doing these kind of
illegal activities you end up
accumulating a lot of Ops
well these days people don't fist fight
yeah
they're trying to end you straight away
they'll run in your house and try and
end you and whoever else is in there so
you better hope you're not in there
having your thug loving session Ralph
because you'll get mocked as well bro so
this is what I'm saying it's like some
of the ways you talk is like you don't
like obviously I don't know your full
background of what and what but the way
you talk is very romanticized about
something that's very real bro like as a
person that I've been in things and I've
been stabbed before and I've been in
places where I shouldn't be and I've
rushed people and I've done things I
shouldn't have done I understand the
deepness of how deep it gets bro so when
you when girls who don't really live
that life and don't really have to get
their hands dirty talk about I want a
guy that is gonna do jungle Justice bruh
that's very dangerous yeah and I know
that you I know you don't mean harm by
it but it is dangerous like do you get
what I'm saying so you have to bro and
you're serious bro I would say just I I
think a man that stays too much in that
box and he's like because the comparison
of nine to five to scammers we already
know what the insinuation is and it's
not as as like uh literal that's what
I'm going for because you gave me a 95
and a scammer I would in that situation
that's when I say a scammer for the fact
that risk taker thinking outside the box
no but look I think I see what I mean
that's the difference I really think I
don't see I really think you guys get
this nine to five wrong and I really
feel like this is holding women back
right because you start out at
McDonald's oh sorry like you you start
out McDonald's you do your thing you go
to college you go to school you work in
nine to five you work at an investment
bank but guess what because you got the
clout you could work remotely so I can
go to anywhere I want in the world and
work remotely and make my money because
I worked at nine to five and guess what
so now you can get the car that you want
you can get buff and I I agree a jungle
man is great but guess what I can afford
to go to the best gym and get buff right
you don't have a physical therapist so
it's like you're right I feel like yeah
you want all those things but you're
looking for in the wrong areas like the
nine to five is the Bedrock that builds
the principle so guess what now they can
do the entrepreneur now they can like do
whatever they want but this is why I say
we're living in a time where everybody
wants everything instantly we're not
like a lot of women nowadays aren't here
to build and have that longevity and
they Unfortunately they don't have that
patience to ride it out with you up
until that point that's why I went as
women a lot of us are looking in the
wrong areas because they're just
thinking oh this person has this this
this okay you fit what I what I like not
to say that I'm personally like that or
any of the ladies are personally like
that but it is what it is nowadays
people want things instantly they want
quick money they want to live their
lifestyle but they're not thinking ahead
they're not thinking that all of this
stuff don't last this could all be taken
away tomorrow instead of sitting down
finding a partner you want to build life
with you want to build a legacy with and
then get there and live your dream life
forever in 10 years again hope that you
keep this mentality because you know
you've done them the bad boy thing so
you're talking a good game serve you
look at you now Hey listen listen it's
not about it's been long though like
being ignorant and stupid yeah but and
that's how I described all that time up
to now it was just ignorance and
stupidness bro and and they didn't
understand
are still lingering they linger do you
get what I'm saying because once you've
you it's like bro if you've been
programmed to be one thing your whole
life bro it's very easy to get pulled
back like you lot as man you know that
like it's something can just pull you
back you can have a road rage moment or
whatever I don't know your someone
messes up your money or something like
that but it can come back very easy so
like I'm not trying to act like I'm
something I'm not bad like you know what
I'm saying like it's real like that but
anyway let me um try and get through
these uh let me run through these all
right Robert Watkins big up for the
people chat my bro he says been a piece
since
um watching love the new look appreciate
that fam bigger
um Riv Gans Riz Howard for the Super
Chat I appreciate that my bro bigger NSX
for Super Chat great show today guys
appreciate you my bro we got T money
official what's the girls
um in the middle asking for a friend
come on on two squids
they're gonna say their Instagrams and
their cash apps at the end don't worry
you gotta give back to the community
[Music]
the UK Economist to your guest in the
middle Haram oh damn oh you get
economists why are you spending your
money on here so
to just say rubbish don't you have
something better today let's leave them
alone man okay
my audience like share subscribe and
give five dollars hey get me they can't
all be scammers bruh
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible